puisque vous êtes impatient nous
recevons aujourd'hui Madame Agnès Diallo
qui depuis le 16 mars dernier exerce la
fonction de directrice exécutive de
l'agence européenne chargé de la gestion
opérationnelle des systèmes
d'information à grande échelle au sein
de l'espace de liberté de sécurité et de
justice qui est également appelé io Lisa
Madame la Directrice exécutive nous
sommes très heureux de vous accueillir
très curieux d'avoir votre avis sur le
fonctionnement de cette agence discrète
mais essentielle à la coopération
européenne dans le domaine policier
judiciaire et des gestions financières
en pratique you Lisa qui existe depuis
2011 et a bénéficié d'un mandat élargi
en 2018 assure la gestion opérationnelle
de trois systèmes d'information créé
pour permettre la libre circulation au
sein de l'espace Schengen le premier le
système d'information Schengen 6-2 créé
en 1995 et récemment modernisé qui
permet aux autorités judiciaires
policières et douanières
d'échanger toutes les informations
utiles sur les personnes recherchées en
vue d'une arrestation sur les personnes
disparues sur les personnes interdites
de séjour ou encore sur les véhicules et
objets servant de preuves dans une
procédure pénale le deuxième système est
le système d'information sur les visas
vis qui facilitent la délivrance des
visas dans les pays de l'espace Schengen
et permet d'identifier les
ressortissants de pays tiers voyageant
avec un visa frauduleux
le troisième et la base Eurodac qui
recense les demandes d'asile dans
l'Union européenne et qui est en cours
de réforme dans le cadre du nouveau
pacte sur la migration et l'asile en
pratique l'agence exerce toutes les
tâches nécessaires au bon fonctionnement
de ces systèmes elle disposait pour cela
d'environ 296 millions d'euros de budget
en crédit de paiement en 2022 et de
trois sites géographiques un siège à
Tallinn un site opérationnel à
Strasbourg et ainsi de secours en
Autriche à sank Yoann
je vais ensuite souligner que l'agence
ioliza est au cœur du développement de
nouveaux systèmes d'information
ambitieux d'une part pour améliorer la
surveillance des frontières et d'autre
part pour améliorer la coopération
judiciaire européenne en matière de
coopération judiciaire on peut citer la
création du système ecodex qui doit
faciliter les échanges entre juridiction
dans le cadre des procédures civiles et
pénales transfrontières on peut aussi
mentionner la conception prévue d'une
plateforme de collaboration au bénéfice
des équipes communes d'enquête qui sont
constitués par les autorités compétentes
d'au moins deux États membres pour mener
certaines enquêtes pénales
en matière de gestion et de surveillance
des frontières extérieures de l'Union
européenne you Lisa supervise la mise en
place de deux systèmes d'information qui
s'inscrivent dans le projet de
frontières intelligente qui avait été
présenté par la commission Junker le
premier système est le système dit
d'entrée sortie qui doit enregistrer les
ressortissants de pays tiers voyageant
dans l'Union européenne pour un court
séjour mais aussi détecté ce qui aurait
fait l'objet d'un refus d'entrer dans
l'Union européenne le second système qui
s'inspire de l'autorisation de voyage
américaine esta et le système européen
d'information et d'autorisation
concernant les voyages système Ethias
il concerne la ressortissants de pays
tiers exemptés de l'obligation de visa
lors de franchissement des frontières
extérieures et doit permettre sur la
base d'un formulaire rempli par les
intéressés d'évaluer s'il rentrait dans
l'Union européenne représente ou non un
risque de sécurité ou un risque
sanitaire
l'action de l'agence
ionisa est aussi indispensable au bon
fonctionnement de la coopération
européenne en matière de justice à faire
intérieure ce qui m'amène Madame la
Directrice à vous poser plusieurs
questions tout d'abord face à ces
chantiers d'importance votre agence
dispose-t-elle des moyens de ses
ambitions en particulier dispostelle de
l'expertise nécessaire en ingénie
informatique ou sous-trait-elle ses
tâches
par ailleurs eu égard à la sensibilité
des systèmes d'information dont vous
assurez la gestion opérationnelle quels
sont les garde-fous qui existent au sein
de votre agence à la fois pour recruter
et employer des personnes compétentes et
dignes de confiance et pour faire face
au risque éventuels de fuite de données
pouvez-vous aussi nous confirmer que
l'agence I ou lisa est bien armé contre
les cyberattaques
je rappelle qu'en mars 2022 la Cour des
comptes de l'Union européenne avait
estimé que le niveau de préparation des
institutions et des agences européennes
face aux instits dans de cybersécurité
était globalement insuffisant
enfin cela ne sera pas une surprise ma
dernière question concerne un sujet de
préoccupation majeur pour l'ensemble des
autorités françaises à l'aube des Jeux
olympiques de 2024 il s'agit de l'entrée
en fonction des systèmes entrée-sortis
et du système Ethias
j'ai d'ailleurs interrogé le
gouvernement à ce sujet la mise en
oeuvre de ces systèmes a déjà fait
l'objet de plusieurs reports
pouvez-vous nous expliquer pourquoi il
ne faut-il pas désormais reporter cette
mise en place à septembre 2024 je vous
remercie
c'est à vous et ensuite nos collègues
vont s'exprimer sur
merci qui a un rôle je le pense en tout
cas assez central dans les institutions
européennes et dans la sécurité et
l'attractivité de l'espace Schengen
permettez-moi de commencer par me
présenter donc je suis Agnès Yello je
suis la directrice exécutive de l'agence
et j'ai pris mes fonctions récemment à
la mi-mars de l'année dernière de cette
année de 2023
auparavant j'avais travaillé dans
l'industrie du digital notamment pendant
10 ans j'ai à la fois travaillé chez un
géant européen de des services du
numérique et puis récemment dans une
entreprise bien connue c'est une
institution française l'ancienne
Imprimerie nationale qui est maintenant
le groupe in qui est un spécialiste
européen de l'identité et en particulier
de l'identité digitale et ces deux
sujets sont des sujets au cœur de
l'activité de l'agence
parmi mes références notamment au
service de la France il y a maintenant
deux ans mes équipes et moi même avion
participé à la construction et à la
gestion opérationnelle du système tac
verif qui servait à la vérification du
passe covid lors de l'ouverture de
l'économie après la pandémie et aussi à
la mise en oeuvre du certificat
covid-européen qui avait permis à partir
du certificat national d'ouvrir les
frontières et de recouvrir les voyages
au moment où ça a été tout à fait
nécessaire
donc mon expérience elle est elle est
assez longue elle est dire avec la mise
en place du système d'information à
grande échelle et à ce titre j'aimerais
souligner qu'à chaque fois que ces
systèmes sont mis en place plusieurs
thématiques sont importantes d'abord la
capacité de cyber résilience à travers
la construction de capacités fortes de
ces systèmes de cybersécurité et aussi
le respect des données avec la stricte
d'application du cadre réglementaire de
la rgpd et ces deux préoccupations
restent des piliers importants de
l'activité et sont au cœur de l'activité
de de l'agence parce qu'elle déploie et
elle opère les infrastructures tout à
fait structurantes et tout à fait
significative pour pour la sécurité de
l'espace européen
vous l'avez rappelé vous avez rappelé je
crois de manière assez extensive les
missions l'émission de l'agence elle est
chargée par son mandat qui a été
renouvelé en 2018 d'assurer la gestion
opérationnelle des systèmes
d'information à grande échelle au cœur
de l'espace Schengen et là aussi depuis
2018 de nouvelles missions qui se sont
élargies et qui ont vocation à conduire
au développement de nouveaux systèmes le
système entrée exit le système aussi
Ethias qui a un système de de comment
dire de prévalidation des des voyageurs
des représentants de pays tiers exemple
de nécessité de visa en Europe
ainsi qu'un certain nombre de composants
dit interopérables dont la connexion
permet de construire ce qui s'appelle
l'architecture d'interopérabilité qui a
vocation à permettre aux différents
systèmes de sécurité et aussi
d'attractivité de différents pays de
l'Espace européen de ce conjoindre et
d'améliorer plus d'efficacité pour les
garde frontières mais aussi pour les
policiers et d'une manière générale
d'améliorer l'attractivité de de
l'espace Schengen pour partager un
chiffre l'espace Schengen l'année
dernière à connu plus de 600 600
millions de voyageurs c'est l'espace
régional le plus attractif de au monde
devant les États-Unis et devant la Chine
et donc c'est une position qu'à travers
les activités de l'agence nous avons
vocation à
renforcer et à et à développer j'allais
dire
depuis
ma prise de fonction les priorités elles
ont été j'allais dire
d'établir et continuer à assurer le bon
fonctionnement de l'agence à la fois sur
ses activités opérationnelles et sur ces
activités nouvelles de développement qui
comme vous l'avez dit était dans les
situations de blocage et au cours de
notre conversation vous m'avez interrogé
sur ce point je partagerai avec vous les
actions qui ont été mises en oeuvre
d'abord les constats et les actions qui
ont été mises en oeuvre depuis pour
permettre un déblocage de la situation
et qu'on puisse aller de l'avant en
particulier sur le système entrée et
sortie qui est le socle de
l'architecture d'interopérabilité et la
vision interopérable au cœur de de la
vision européenne
sur les moyens humains financiers
technologiques sur lesquels vous m'avez
vous m'avez interrogé l'agence a
aujourd'hui environ 350
collaborateurs propres elle bénéficie de
la possibilité de évidemment s'appuyer
sur des expertises techniques à
l'extérieur de l'agence
et son budget vous l'avez rappelé il
était autour de 290 millions un tout
petit peu moins en 2023 mais c'est
l'ordre de grandeur alors
sont-ils suffisants on peut toujours
faire mieux et on peut toujours élargir
je pense le cadre des ressources mais
avec les ressources dont elles dispose
aujourd'hui à la fois en termes de
compétences techniques en termes de
compétences clés notamment des
compétences d'architecture des
compétences de gestion de produits des
compétences de orchestration des projets
qui sont vraiment centrales pour ces
activités mais aussi les compétences
d'exploitation de système d'information
il me semble que elle elle parvient à
remplir de mieux en mieux
des émissions et j'en veux pour preuve
qu'il y a il y a de cela uniquement
quelques semaines en fait il y a eu les
résultats du questionnaire de
satisfaction 10 clients qui est rempli
par les États membres qui sont
utilisateurs de nos services et que les
résultats étaient d'une satisfaction
supérieure à 90 95% sur l'ensemble des
systèmes dont nous avons la
responsabilité aujourd'hui ce qui est
pour moi le témoin du fait que ces
activités sont reconnues pour leur
valeur leur stabilité et leur bonne
contribution aux missions qui qui sont
confiées à l'agence
maintenant bien sûr il faudrait que pour
accompagner sa croissance elle continue
de se développer sur sur des sujets qui
sont centraux vous avez une cité
notamment la partie les compétences en
termes de cybersécurité depuis l'année
dernière il me semble peut-être même
l'année d'avant mais très certainement
depuis l'année dernière des nouvelles
possibilités de renforcer ses
compétences ont été ouvertes en
discussion avec
la Commission et le Parlement et nous
avons déjà recruté un certain nombre de
collaborateurs qui permettent de venir
renforcer très directement et on a
construit une équipe de cybersécurité
qui est très reconnue au sein des
institutions et qui fait référence
d'ailleurs dans le métier sur ce sujet
là
donc on se renforce sur cette partie là
sur la partie sur les sujets qui sont
très à la protection des données et au
rgpd nous avons aussi le cadre
réglementaire qui est strictement mis en
oeuvre et qui est strictement comment
dire j'allais dire respecter et nous
sommes accompagnés par le
dps dont la traduction en français et le
contre exactement merci
pour la traduction
en charge le contrôleur européen en
charge la protection des données avec
lesquelles nous avons des audits
réguliers qui sont qui sont conduits
nous avons aussi une une personne en
charge une équipe pardon en charge de la
protection des données au sein de
l'agence qui intervient à la fois sur
les mécanismes de contrôle interne mais
aussi sur leur mise en oeuvre
opérationnelle dans chacun des
déploiements et des développements que
nous faisons
voilà pour un premier premier
oui merci Madame la Directrice moi
j'aurai quelques quelques questions
d'abord sur sur le système sur la mise
en oeuvre du système Ethias
entrer sorti Schengen qui sont
effectivement
lancés depuis longtemps et pour lequel
on a vu plusieurs
reports de mise en œuvre et alors que ce
sont des systèmes qui ont vocation a
fonctionné ensemble il y a une décision
de décupler la mise en oeuvre de lin par
rapport à la mise en oeuvre de l'autre
donc ce que vous pouvez nous dire un peu
où se prennent ces décisions est-ce que
c'est des décisions politiques ou est-ce
que c'est des décisions techniques et et
où se trouve en réalité la difficulté
qui fait que on reporte systématiquement
la mise en oeuvre des deux et que ça a
été des couplé et d'une manière un peu
plus précise sur ce système sur ce
système Ethias est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire ce qui sera demandé aux
personnes qui est-ce qui sera
formellement demandé aux personnes qui
demanderont
cette autorisation
l'ensemble de leur nationalité je
m'entends si je pose la question c'est
parce que je suis très préoccupé par une
chose c'est par les personnes qui sont
binationales et qui se verrait refuser
le dispositif Ethias si ils annoncent
qu'ils ont une ils ont une nationalité
européenne sans avoir de passeport qui
va avec parce qu'ils utilisent un autre
passeport et donc en fait
c'est important de savoir si on
demandera aux personnes la liste de
l'ensemble de leur nationalité lorsque
demanderont une autorisation et enfin
sur le la prise de décision derrière la
manière dont les choses sont prises
est-ce que c'est une décision européenne
ou est-ce que c'est une décision qui
sera liée au pays de première entrée qui
sera annoncé dans le formulaire
et est-ce que
l'origine de la décision sera bien
précise s'il y avait un refus
sur
un autre dispositif sur le système le
dispositif qui a été accordé qui a été
on a travaillé dessus il y a quelques
semaines en commission et ça a été
validé il y a pas très longtemps au
Conseil c'est-à-dire les le visa
j'imagine que si vous aussi qui allez
vous en occuper
donc je ferai pas je j'aimais pas cette
question enfin une dernière question sur
Eurodac
je constate qu'au minimum en France on a
une difficulté avec le redack c'est la
question des bornes et de leur coûts et
de leur disponibilité et ce qu'il y a
quelque chose qui est prévu pour que
finalement les bords de relax soit
utilisable enfin que Eurodac les
terminaux eurodacs soient pas cher et
axe est disponible en plus grand nombre
merci pour vos questions je vais je vais
commencer si vous voulez bien par la
situation d'ensemble je peux être qui
prévalait au moment de mon arrivée
j'allais dire sur le système entrée
sortie ce système il est important parce
qu'il est le socle de l'interopérabilité
européenne et donc c'est sur ce
fondement là que viennent se construire
les autres systèmes et notamment le
système Ethias qui a vocation comme vous
le disiez à
peu près enregistrer et très validé la
demande d'accession à l'espace Schengen
de des représentants de pays tiers qui
sont exemps de demande de visa ce qu'il
faut également que je précise si vous ne
me permettez c'est que ces systèmes sont
construits à travers leur socle
réglementaire à travers leur socle légal
d'une manière combinatoire c'est à dire
que le second système utilise des
éléments du premier et le troisième des
éléments du second donc ils sont
vraiment liés dans une chaîne de
construction
ce qui fait que quand les difficultés
sont rencontrées sur l'un ou sur l'autre
par un effet de domino elle elle se
cascade sur l'ensemble de la chaîne
et cette précision est importante
j'allais dire parce que elle est c'est
aussi un des éléments de l'explication
du pourquoi le retard
mais c'est pas le seul en fait à mon
arrivée à ma prise de fonction je pense
le l'addition qui a été soulignée par
l'ensemble des États membres la
Commission je pense l'ensemble des
parties prenantes au sujet au dossier
c'était vraiment de mettre l'en face sur
la nécessité de relancer le train de
l'interopérabilité alors pour bien
résoudre un problème il faut bien en
comprendre les causes racines donc ma
première priorité c'était vraiment de
comprendre qu'est-ce qui génère c'est
ces difficultés de mise en oeuvre et je
dirais qu'il y en a essentiellement
trois peut-être en aparté il y a
évidemment les impacts de la crise covid
la raréfaction de la de la capacité de
ce pour voir en
puce qui est un impact sur tout ce qui
est relatif au digital mais
je pense que c'est ces difficultés là
ont été sans doute surmonter et que à
mon arrivée il en demeurait trois qui me
paraissaient être les plus importantes
pour le sujet qui nous préoccupe
aujourd'hui la première c'est que le
niveau on est je pense que le
consortium qui était au service de
l'agence à ce moment-là était
certainement pas au meilleur de sa
capacité de performance on va dire comme
ça et nécessitait une meilleure une
meilleure
un meilleur pilotage et une meilleure
collaboration avec la jambe ok
certainement ce premier élément là la
deuxième était je pense qu'il y a une
situation assez anquée liée à la
complexité de mise en oeuvre des
systèmes et à cet élément de maillage
très fort entre entre les systèmes à
commencer par le système en très sorti
et qui s'est traduit dans les fêtes par
une j'allais dire l'absence de progrès
notable sur les 12 peut-être 18 mois
dernier qui s'est constaté dans
l'ensemble des États membres par
l'impossibilité de sa propriété le
système et de commencer à travailler
dessus ne serait-ce que dans un état on
va dire intermédiaire et je pense la
troisième chose ce qu'il faut toujours
regarder à l'intérieur aussi la manière
les choses se font et je pense que les
modes de travail qui étaient mis en
oeuvre à la fois en interne et avec nos
partenaires ne permettait pas
nécessairement de tirer le plein
potentiel de la collaboration entre
l'agence à l'interne entre les équipes
et aussi avec ses prestataires et donc
c'est sur la base de ces observations si
vous voulez que
ce que ce que j'ai j'ai résolu de faire
c'est d'impulser une une nouvelle
stratégie que j'ai appelé stratégie de
résolution avec le soutien de la
commissaire mais aussi de la
commissariat Johansson mais aussi du
conseil d'administration l'agence dans
lequel siège l'entend l'ensemble des
États membres pour pouvoir résoudre la
situation et permettre de relancer le
bon fonctionnement on va dire de du
développement de ces systèmes avec un
impact sur l'ensemble de la chaîne de
Domino et cette stratégie elle est elle
répond j'allais dire par trois piliers à
la situation initiale que que je vous ai
décrite la première c'est de remobiliser
très fortement nos prestataires parce
que le processus de sélection a je pense
permis de d'être tout à fait dans les
règles de d'achat publique et de
sélectionner la meilleure proposition
mais une fois que cette proposition a
été sélectionnée il reste à engager et
et à bien travailler et à bien piloter
ses prestataires et s'assurer que sur
des sujets très complexes entre la
collaboration se passe assez bien et
donc on a beaucoup travaillé avec nos
prestataires sur cette remobilisation
au meilleur niveau au sein de ces
organisations
et je dois dire qu'on a observé une une
remobilisation et une reprise d'énergie
et d'engagement de leur part qui s'est
traduit par le fait que les compétences
engagées le niveau d'engagement le
niveau de seniorité mobilisé sur les
systèmes et a été tout à fait tout à
fait au rendez-vous depuis que nous
l'avons mobilisé et bien sûr nous
continuons à le faire même si c'est un
chemin qui est qui est encore en cours
donc le premier axe de travail ça a été
de remobiliser le deuxième c'est de
résoudre opérationnellement
vous avez noté mon propos autour de
cette situation très complexe et très
intriquée et pour la résoudre mon parti
pris a été de dire simplifiant et
focalisons nous sur un périmètre plus
restreint
qui va nous permettre d'apporter pour
nos parties prenantes des résultats
certes plus restreints mais visible et
qui va leur permettre et qui va
permettre à chacun de recommencer à
travailler sur sur les systèmes donc on
a travaillé sur ce qu'on a appelé un
périmètre intermédiaire du système qui a
du coup permis de focaliser les efforts
et de résoudre les difficultés
techniques les plus fortes et la
troisième chose c'est de renouveler donc
remobiliser résoudre et renouveler et on
a renouvelé fortement les modes de
travail en interne de l'agence en
adoptant des nouvelles pratiques que
inspirer fortement aussi de des
meilleures pratiques qui qui sont en
oeuvre dans l'industrie du digital
autour des méthodologies Agiles d'un
esprit de collaboration plus fort et qui
nous ont permis de travailler un rythme
plus rapide
je crois que ces trois éléments et je me
réduit le partager avec vous ont permis
de débloquer la situation sur le système
entrée et sortie et d'arriver à une
situation où on a finalement dépassé le
le blocage et on a repris en main
j'allais dire le le développement et
donc on a une meilleure maîtrise de du
calendrier de de des travaux sur sur
l'avancement de des systèmes et donc
aussi avec les effets en chaîne sur les
systèmes qui suivent
maintenant tout n'est pas fait et il
reste encore bien sûr énormément de
travail vous m'avez interrogé sur le
calendrier je pense qu'il y a il y a
deux éléments qu'il faut sans doute
distinguer dans dans la construction et
la mise en oeuvre des systèmes il y a un
premier élément qui est de construire le
moteur si vous me permettez le
l'expression c'est à dire de construire
le système et de l'amener à un point où
il est robuste viable sécurisé et il
permet de remplir ses fonctions et c'est
le périmètre de sur lequel se concentre
l'agence et son périmètre d'action de
par son mandat une fois ce système
construit
ma proposition auprès de la commissaire
et du Conseil administration et des
États membres a été de dire ce système
sera mis à disposition de de des parties
prenantes qui ont vocation à l'utiliser
et une décision devra à ce moment-là
être pris sur la bonne date j'allais
dire de mise en oeuvre qui permet
d'accommoder les circonstances des États
membres et permettre ainsi de distinguer
une décision technique qui est de
l'ordre technique et opérationnel qui
est de l'ordre de du mandat de l'agence
d'une décision de nature davantage
politique bien sûr ces deux éléments ont
un point d'adhérence mais la décision de
nature politique est à mon sens hors du
mandat de de l'agence strictement
sur votre question relative au système
Ethias
alors j'ai fait une intervention au
conseil au début du mois de juin pour
présenter l'avancée du des travaux et la
date est prise j'allais dire un
rendez-vous a été pris avec le conseil à
l'automne prochain pour proposer une un
nouveau calendrier et une nouvelle une
nouvelle comment dire un nouveau une
nouvelle marche de de des travaux donc
la décision sur qui va permettre
d'enterrer le nouveau calendrier sera
prise à ce moment là mais entre temps
l'agence a proposé un nouveau une
nouvelle approche dite par vague qui
permet de manière graduelle de mettre en
oeuvre les différents systèmes qui
constituent le train d'interopérabilité
de manière à la fois j'allais dire
réaliste c'est-à-dire avec une certaine
maîtrise sur le calendrier qui permet
aussi de maîtriser les risques de mise
en oeuvre on va dire conjointe trop
ambitieuse et à la fois avec un comment
dire une évolution par vague qui permet
que tous les 6 à 9 mois une avancée
réelle soit faite sur la thématique de
l'interopérabilité la première vague
c'est évidemment le système entrée
sortie avec du coup la promesse on va
dire d'une amélioration de la sécurité
aux frontières la deuxième vague aura
vocation à mettre en œuvre le système
Ethias avec pour le coup une
amélioration de l'expérience des
voyageurs au sens large j'allais dire
aux frontières de l'Europe et à
l'intérieur de l'espace
merci alors vas-y ajoute
national ou européenne enfin la décision
finale
[Musique]
des systèmes sont elle est bi parti donc
il y a une composante centrale qui est
le système central qui est construit par
l'agence l'agence a pour mandat pour
chacun de ces systèmes et la mandat qui
a un mandat réglementaire donc elle est
le périmètre de fonctionnalités d'action
vous m'interroger tout à l'heure sur
le cas d'usage c'est à dire qu'est-ce
qu'on a l'un ou l'autre passeport le de
ces possibilités qui sont des on va dire
des expressions spécifiques ces
éléments-là sont spécifiés dans les
aspects réglementaires et leurs
déclinaisons ils sont confiés comme
mandat à l'agence dont la fonction
la demande elle se fait de toute façon
toujours
sur le même portail et c'est et elle est
examiner au niveau par le par le enfin
j'ai pas les opérateurs du fichier de
manière de manière centrale est-ce que
derrière à partir du est-ce que on doit
dire où choses qu'on va de ce que le
voyageur doit dire où est ce qui va et
ce qu'après c'est une décision nationale
où une décision européenne
et donc en fait c'est à dire que il peut
y avoir
est-ce que ça veut dire que il y a une
et donc une fois que la personne si elle
a un refus au niveau national une
personne qui va refaire une demande en
disant je vais pas en France je vais en
Italie ça va être bloquer tout de suite
comme les visas
je les ai visités les équipes du sneave
qui en fait inscrivent au sein du
fichier l'instruction qui a été faite de
la demande et le le le
la décision qui a été prise et et cette
donnée va être disponible pour un
prochain État membre la décision
coffrale le prochain État membre à
partir c'est des demandes au demande
c'est c'est des demandes c'est comme les
visas en fait c'est à la fin c'est la
décision c'est le pays de première
entrée qui va décider exactement et non
parce que derrière il y a la question
des recours au cas où la décision est
négative et donc c'est des recours
nationaux le vraiment être très proche
de du système des visas du visa et
d'ailleurs les équipes françaises qui
sont vocation à travailler sur le
système Ethias aujourd'hui manipule le
système visa à des fins de monter en
compétences
on peut donc imaginer que ces procédures
vont être accélérées par rapport aux
procédures
conventionnelles ça va permettre une
accélération des procédures ça va
permettre à un gain de temps pour les
demandes c'est tout à fait l'objectif
ça c'est pas une accélération puisque
aujourd'hui il y a rien
mais disons que ça va permettre de
fluidifier parce que en arrivant à la
frontière Schengen le voyageur bonnet
Fidée d'un représentant d'un pays tiers
aura son sa validation de prix entrée et
donc la validation sera accélérée le
geste de validation j'allais dire à la
frontière sera
plus fluidifier et accéléré alors il est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui ce contrôle
spécifique n'existe pas mais le fait
qu'il soit traité de manière digitale va
permettre de et qu'il soit anticipé sur
le moment d'arriver à la frontière va
permettre de en réduire l'incidence sur
sur le passage frontières
largement accéléré le procédure
aux États-Unis on avait
conventionnellement avant
le système Ethias et et alors je sais
pas s'il est calqué mais il est proche
il a il est il est il est symétrique
Jean-Yves avait posé une question
notamment sur les moyens liés aux bornes
c'est un plus un sujet voilà matériel
que que probablement de soft mais malgré
tout il y a quand même une difficulté
d'accès
pour le coup national parce que les
bornes d'accès sont liés à l'usage qui
fait sur le territoire il y a une
distinction comme c'est pour ça que je
faisais la précision entre système
central et 6 et sont pendant au niveau
national et donc les bandes sont
directement liées à l'accès au système
national
oui mais vous vous
voilà
l'agence et je dirais peut-être
heureusement
n'a pas vocation en tout cas elle a
certainement pas la prétention ni les
moyens de voyez de piloter de manière
très fine au niveau de chacun des États
c'est vraiment un élément qui est
important ce qui est important c'est
d'avoir un dispositif qui n'exige pas
des terminaux qui coûtent 100.000 euros
à chaque fois
le mandat que c'est parti prenant dans
les États membres ont voté à travers le
trilogue législatif
un petit point aussi sur la temporalité
vous avez en partie répondu mais mais je
votre réponse reste imprécise à mon goût
parce que je vous ai posé une question
précise sur les Jeux Olympiques donc et
sur l'échéance des Jeux Olympiques
est-ce que on peut penser être prêt pour
les Jeux olympiques ou est-ce que vous
considérez et je comprends que ce soit
une décision politique mais est-ce que
vous considérez on est prêt opérationnel
pour les Jeux olympiques ou que il vaut
mieux pas utiliser système avant les
Jeux Olympiques et puis laisser passer
je
voilà je vous ai répondu de manière
imprécise parce que réellement je pense
que mais je vais vous répondre ce que je
peux
[Rires]
je vais vous répondre ce que je peux je
crois qu'aujourd'hui la priorité des
Jeux Olympiques pour la France mais de
manière générale pour l'Europe et tout à
fait
perçu de manière forte au niveau de la
commission au niveau politique et en
France vous allez dire et il y a une
bonne coordination qui est mise en place
pour que la mise en place du système
n'impacte pas
cet événement qui encore une fois une
visibilité pour l'Europe pour la France
et pour l'Europe donc pardon
sur le plan technique
l'orientation et de dire qu'on mettra on
fera en sorte que le système soit
prêt à être mis en oeuvre au moment du
deuxième semestre 2024 c'est la
proposition qui est faite et encore une
fois cette proposition n'est pas
entérinée
elle est pas entérinée c'est la base de
travail sur laquelle l'agence et ses
parties prenantes au travail une fois
qu'elle sera voilà donc
ce soit pas facile parce que il y a
encore beaucoup d'incertitudes de
déblocage politique
deuxième semestre ça veut dire que le
dispositif sera pas mis en place pour
les JO
ce qui est certain c'est que le
dispositif ne sera pas mis en place si
il a une incidence tout à fait négative
sur sur la tenue des JO je pensais
l'assurance qu'on peut qu'on peut
un système qui n'est pas celui là mais
qui est mis en place au sein du
ministère service étrangers si vous
allez à Nantes j'imagine que c'est les
mêmes genres le système France visa qui
se développe depuis 18 mois qui est qui
a quand même montré
énormément de difficultés à fonctionner
correctement
compte tenu de l'intérieur des des bases
qu'il consulte ce qui est difficile pour
les difficiles pour les consulats et qui
montre aussi que probablement voilà ce
ce si c'est les mêmes bases qui sont
interrogés par Ethias on risque d'avoir
quand même dans la au niveau
opérationnel au début quelques
difficultés de la même manière c'est la
raison pour laquelle je vous pose la
question sur Evisa c'est que quand on
voit les difficultés sur France visa en
matière de mise en œuvre alors qu'elle
n'avait pas été tout à fait prévu
je crois quand on avait vu les
propositions de règlement sur sur sur ce
dispositif que la Commission n'avait pas
encore tout à fait bien trouver les
difficultés de la mise en oeuvre de du
système quand elle l'a proposé donc
voilà c'est c'est à dire c'est après que
les difficultés arrivent et
moi je pense qu'il faut je vais garder
une posture assez humble en fait en fait
c'est des systèmes qui ont des
composantes techniques et en tant que
tels sont complexes mais surtout elles a
elles ont vocation et à être utilisées
par des opérationnels sur le terrain et
dont pour lesquels en fait ça change
très significativement les gestes
métiers et donc il y a pour tous les
systèmes ça fait plus de 20 ans que je
je
j'observe la mise en oeuvre système et
depuis 10 ans d'encore plus près parce
que j'en ai la responsabilité propre
pour tous les systèmes que j'ai vu
mettre en oeuvre il y a toujours une
phase de rodage donc cette phase de
rodage elle peut être plus ou moins
forte mais c'est il y a toujours une
phase de rodage dans laquelle on affine
on a juste on
relance des fonctionnalités qui
n'avaient pas été imaginées parce que
les utilisateurs sur le terrain disent
bah tiens il manque tel et tel élément
et ça permet de oui de faire le la
finage fin entre la théorie et le et la
pratique j'allais dire
voilà donc prenons en compte ces
éléments là je l'assurance que je peux
vous donner encore une fois qui est sans
doute au-delà de de
ce qui met autorisé de partager c'est
que je crois que la complexité de mise
en œuvre et les incidences
opérationnelles que ça peut avoir
notamment sur le
la période des Jeux Olympiques et des
Jeux paralympiques et tout à fait bien
pris en compte dans le déploiement du
système
une petite question sur le coup du
dispositif est-ce qu'aujourd'hui je n'ai
pas entendu peut-être que ça a été
évoqué est-ce qu'on a une idée du coup
et puis du coup pour le citoyen est-ce
que on a évoqué ce que coûterait cette
déclaration Ethias
alors c'est
le il y a un coup de la même manière que
le système esta
c'est le demandeur qui paye je ne
pourrai pas vous donner le la
tarification précise je pense qu'elle
doit certainement être inscrite en dans
le règlement mais elle a effectivement
il y a effectivement comme pour le
système esta il y a un moment où il y a
il y a une il y a une étape de paiement
qui est prévu dans le système
concernant les moyens aussi essayer de
repréciser un petit peu parce que
le rapport de la européenne des comptes
avaient précisé en 2019-2020-2021 que
les moyens de l'agence par rapport à ces
perspectives de croissance était assez
réduits rationnel en ce qui concerne la
cybersécurité etc des équipes étaient
mises en place donc ça veut dire et
j'estime que
mon visage que en face vous ayez des
moyens mis à disposition qui soit qui
soit conséquent ou alors vous vivez un
moyen constant et en tirant les pots de
ficelles
donc le fonctionnement est tel que le la
le mandat de mise en oeuvre d'un système
de son développement et de sa gestion et
associés à un certain nombre une
enveloppe à une enveloppe en termes de
ressources et une enveloppe financière
avec des compétences qui sont des
compétences techniques
jugés nécessaires pour la construction
du système mais aussi des compétences
évidemment transverses parce que il faut
gérer des de la finance des achats
publics des ressources humaines de la
compliance c'est donc il y a un certain
nombre de de voilà de fonctions qui sont
transverses qui viennent appuyer en fait
les éléments techniques et l'enveloppe
est liée au périmètre identifié dans le
cadre réglementaire et les gens donc met
en oeuvre j'allais dire sur un petit
encore une fois je pense qu'on peut
toujours faire mieux et qu'on peut on
peut on peut on peut et d'ailleurs dans
le dialogue
budgétaire que l'agence a régulièrement
deux fois par an avec un une révision on
va dire de la loi de financement tous
les ans il y a une rediscution voilà
qui permet un ajustement selon les les
nécessités
identifiées c'est ajustement il est
justifié qui typiquement a permis
l'année dernière la construction de
cette nouvelle équipe de cybersécurité
qui s'est justifiait par l'acuité plus
forte aujourd'hui qui a trois quatre ans
de ce sujet là pour les activités de
l'agence
complètement
ah oui et c'est vraiment une agence
européenne à la fois sur le site de
Strasbourg et à Tallinn sur le siège
opérationnel où il y a une
représentation de toutes les
nationalités avec un équilibre auquel on
veille entre les représentations de des
différents des différents pays
est-ce que je peux me permettre
d'insister un peu sur un point qui pour
moi est essentiel sur la mise en place
des tiens c'est la question des
binationaux parce qu'il y a énormément
de binationaux qui vivent dans des pays
qui sont pas soumis à visa
européen et nationalité du pays de
résidence que ce soit au Canada que ce
soit Australie que ce soit aux
États-Unis Mexique Brésil etc qui n'ont
pas de passeport européen
et donc en fait la question qui que je
pose c'est est-ce que dans les questions
qui seront posées et dans la manière
l'algorithme qui sera derrière et ce que
à partir du moment où une personne dit
qu'elle a une nationalité européenne
parce que c'est la question lui est
posée la réponse sera systématiquement
négative ou est-ce qu'on examinera un
néanmoins le dossier sur la base de ce
qu'elle donne c'est à dire de son
passeport de son pays de résidence et
les autres informations qu'elle donne
parce que suivant que c'est l'un ou
l'autre ça ça aura des conséquences pour
des centaines de milliers de personnes
de citoyens européens qui hors de
l'union et qui n'ont bien des cas pas la
possibilité d'avoir un passeport
européen
alors le l'instruction du système Ethias
elle se fait
conformément j'allais dire à encore une
fois le mandat basé sur le règlement
européen qui instruit le qui propose
l'instruction de de
la possibilité d'accéder ou pas au
territoire le système Ethias il est
plutôt
orienté vers les représentants des pays
tiers donc si c'est un représentant
européen pour répondre en tout cas
essayer de répondre de manière
spécifique à vos questions si il est
représentant s'il est européen il est
par définition
exempt de visa
s'il est des personnes qui n'ont pas la
capacité de prouver leur nationalité
européenne la seule chose qui vont c'est
qu'ils vont à dire qu'ils l'ont sauf
qu'en fait quand ils arrivent quand ils
arrivent en Europe ils montrent leur
passeport canadien par exemple et donc
en fait ils arrivent comme canadien
aujourd'hui et ils ne pour la question
c'est s'il ne peuvent plus arriver comme
canadien parce que la question l'ESTA
leur sera refusée parce qu'ils ont dit
qu'ils ont une nationalité européenne
que ce soit française grec ou autre là
on est devant une vraie difficulté parce
qu'à ce moment-là ça veut dire que en
parallèle il faut lancer et une campagne
d'information très très sérieuse avec
des moyens très lourds pour permettre à
tous ces binationaux qui ne pourront
plus rentrer en Europe tant qu'ils n'ont
pas de documents européens de disposer
de documents européens et c'est des
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
sont concernées
je sais pas si je serai aussi comment
dire aussi
voilà peut-être ils peuvent faire valoir
leur nationalité mais le sujet le
problème c'est la carte ne serait-ce que
l'obtention d'un document d'identité
quand vous êtes hors de l'Union
européenne n'est pas une opération
simple
c'est pas une opération simple ce sont
des pays où les rendez-vous sont
impossibles ce sont des pays où les
consulats sont à des centres parfois des
milliers de kilomètres
et donc c'est pas toujours quelque chose
qui est évident et en plus c'est des
choses qui se font voilà si les
personnes ne sont même pas informés on a
déjà vu
de notre côté nous on a vu complètement
en bouteillée les consulats dès lors
qu'il y a eu les les pendant quelques
mois les les mesures de de d'arriver en
Europe pour des raisons impérieuses
toutes les personnes qui en fait il y a
des on avait énormément de binationaux
qui n'avaient pas de passeport européen
et qui ne pouvait pas rentrer en Europe
parce qu'il n'avait pas de motif
impérieux et donc depuis bien entendu
ils demandent des passeports mais ça
embolise totalement les dispositifs et
donc en réalité c'est pas aussi simple
que ça de répondre à de dire il suffit
qu'il pouvait le prouve leur identité
c'est quelque chose ça va être quelque
chose qui va emboliser l'ensemble de nos
dips de nos représentations
diplomatiques et consulaires pendant des
mois ou même peut-être quelques années
je si vous me permettez j'aurais un
regard un peu différent je pense que le
système est le système Ethias à cet
égard
ne change rien et c'est peut-être ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui le binational
quand il se présente à la frontière
Schengen un État membre il doit faire il
doit produire son identité alors soit il
produit son identité nationale où il
produit ça sa deuxième identité cet
élément là ne va pas changer demain ce
que le système esthias va apporter
c'est qu'il va permettre de digitaliser
ce processus mais le fait que le
représentant d'un pays tiers arrive à la
frontière et se voit accorder l'accès au
territoire va rester similaire à
aujourd'hui donc je voilà donc sur votre
question de de la binationalité et
l'impossibilité de produire la preuve de
son passeport européen je dirais que la
circonstance et la même qu'aujourd'hui
il va devoir faire la preuve de son
autre nationalité et il par rapport à
cette nationalité là le garde frontière
va pour le coup du pays membre va
qualifier si c'est un voyageur comme on
dit techniquement bonne affidé ou pas
mais le système Ethias en tant que tel
ne va pas rajouter une complexité il va
la digitaliser il va être digitalisé le
processus parce que moi j'ai compris
d'un courrier avec la Commissaire que
les
Ethias répondrai non
à une personne qui a une nationalité
européenne
c'est pas une question de faire la
preuve ou pas c'est à partir du moment
où il est là
oui
il doit faire la preuve demain comme
aujourd'hui il permet de valider son
autre nationalité
cette démarche va rester similaire
simplement il sera
bon
je vous assure que non c'est à dire que
dans l'autre sens si vous êtes canadien
et que vous dites que vous et que vous
n'avez pas de passeport canadien et vous
rentrez au Canada on va pas vous
délivrer parce qu'en fait on va
considérer que vous êtes hors champ
bon ben
les acteurs des Français étrangers on va
considérer que vous êtes hors champ
parce qu'on veut dire on n'a pas besoin
de vous le délivrer vous n'en avez pas
besoin
voilà et la difficulté c'est que en fait
voilà il suffit si on répond pas
correctement aux questions c'est aussi
un problème
il vaut mieux en général correctement
donc si on vous demande est-ce que vous
avez une deuxième nationalité même si
vous n'avez pas de passeport par rapport
à cette nationalité c'est quand même
mieux de répondre correctement
même si vous pouvez jouer sur le fait
que peut-être il y a ça va pas s'écrire
de la même manière il y aura pas de
concordance et que ça c'est quand même
mieux de répondre correctement mais
dans un cas d'usage assez particulier je
dirais que pour le cas majoritaire le
système Ethias le cas majoritaire des
représentants
politiciens exemples de visa c'est quand
même comme quand on voyage aux
États-Unis qu'on va aller ça c'est quand
même le cas de figure où il y a pas
d'opposition et où en fait le système à
vocation à fluidifier et à permettre par
un prêt enregistrement qu'on a ce
d'entre nous qui avons déjà voyagé aux
Etats-Unis tous pratiqué et qui qui
voilà dans les cas qui n'ont pas
l'occasion à poser de problème ne pose
pas de problème pour pour la plupart des
pour la plupart des gens mais qui en
revanche permet de resserrer les mailles
du filet pour les cas où on a besoin
d'accentuer la sécurité et et et et aux
frontières
merci de m'avoir reçu merci bonne
journée